if I think we're going to make a real
difference and have some fun doing it
then we'll go for it and obviously
something like Virgin Galactic fits that
criteria perfectly you know we're having
and a lot of fun it's it's it's a it's a
hard work you know but later this year
we should finally succeeded and it
Virgin Galactic I suspect we'll end up
being this sort of you know the umbrella
for the rest of the rest of Virgin Group
I mean it and it'll be a fantastic sort
of halo effect I think the rest of the
Virgin I was determined not to ask you
win because I imagine you're sick of
that question what what are the next
sort of one of the big hurdles to get
over to get up we think all the hurdles
that there have been take now and you
know we had another rocket test
yesterday which went really well and you
know so we are ready hopeful that we're
almost there but we've got to put all
the pieces together we're not going to
go until 100% sure it's you know
obviously safe and and but I you know I
would be very very disappointed if it
doesn't happen this year I was I was
actually there on spaceship one I won
the XPrize that day on the Mojave Desert
and I hadn't thought of the excitement
of space let's leave
you've carried through all these years
or did you also kind of get re-energized
with that idea that a certain point now
ii-i've I'm still fascinated by space I
mean you know we are this tiny dot in
and you know the space is infinite it's
there to explore it's it has so many
possibilities and and not just the
possibilities of putting people into
space but you know what we can do with
satellites from space how that can you
know transform things back back here on
there what we can do one day with
intercontinental travel
the sky's not the limit and this isn't
just about space tourism this is you see
that as a beginning
yes I mean I think you know 80% of
people want to would love to go to space
if they could afford it so the market is
enormous for poor you know space
tourists who want to go and want to
experience space travel and that will
help us fund things like point-to-point
travel it'll help us fund things like
our satellite program it'll help us
it'll help us fund hotels in space it'll
help us fund deep-space exploration one
day it'll help us fund mining of
asteroids you know I mean it's there's
there's a lot a lot to do I went out in
the zero-g photos in my case out of Cape
Canaveral a few months ago it was really
really really cool you've done that I
have done it I mean I you know just to
you know lie on the bottom the plane and
just suddenly find yourself you're
lifting up to the ceiling there's
nothing like it and I think the the
exciting thing about voting galactic is
that instead of it just being a you know
ten second wonder you're going to just
be you know floating around you know
four minutes rather than seconds and and
then looking out of these magnificent
windows but you know back at back on
this beautiful air you said Virgin
America here in San Francisco and I
wonder what what your take is in Silicon
Valley you know that they just have this
discussion with all these interesting
entrepreneurs some of them have been at
Google and and havel in other places
other startups as well all focused
really kind of on the movement of
electrons on some level to change is
this what what you're taking so can I
would you like about it
Oh minutes most must be one of them
maybe the most exciting place an
entrepreneurial place in the world and
with with extraordinary people with
extraordinary ideas and the resources to
get out and and you know put those ideas
into practice and I think
you know I think a lot of the problems
of the world can be sold from Silicon
Valley you know whether it's your
feeding you know feeding the poor of the
world whether it's pulling people out of
poverty and you know I think the world
will be a lot better place you know in
10 years time than it is today
kiteboarding from the pictures I saw
from the little mai tai event looks like
you've gotten pretty good at it you like
it why well I absolutely love I love
kite surfing it's one of the you know
one of the yeah this was a great way of
just getting out there getting getting
away from the mobile phone getting away
from the the iPad and and yeah just
getting myself fit and you know and
having some fun
the my event was great in that there
were three girls volunteered to jump on
my back and see if we could be to
Guinness World Record and and somehow we
succeeded so we all came back with the
biggest grins on our faces ever I saw
those pictures on music industry you
know you've been deeply involved with
that nonetheless have survived the music
industry Apple made a big investment or
sound like you brought like a big
investment in beats in the in the
streaming music industry when you look
at that business now what do you see the
sort of difficulties are well I mean I
think we were very fortunate to sell out
of a record company when we did and
there was right at the peak of the
industry and you know since then largely
due to Apple
the industry has imploded and you know
live music soda as well merchandising
music as well but artists to make money
out of their sales and their music you
know it's pretty abysmal so you know
apples new move in it you know it may be
a small wave you know giving back what
they've taken
great would be great if it could succeed
and be great devotees could make a bit
of money out of it what's next for
Virgin America is a Love Field deserve
you know IPO in the future or are you
looking for more finance because it
seems like it's been kind of on the edge
of that for a while I'm not sure what
I'm allowed to say which most likely
means that something's up but yeah but
there there are yeah they've been rumors
of an IPO we'll see what happens there
and it will continue we're hoping I mean
I think we might even get the Love Field
decision today and we're obviously
hoping hoping for good news for hoping
that ultimately the right decision
normally gets made hopefully the right
decision will be made and and that'll be
a great a great breakthrough for Virgin
America because you know it is really
difficult to get get gates and in you
know major cities